ben is well aware of the fascination
surrounding him and j.lo and while they
may be keeping things closer to the vest
this time around ben also can't help but
celebrate it
i try to conceal the embarrassing things
about my life and only reveal the
the appeal
that includes benefit 2.0 ben told wsj
magazine quote i am very lucky in my
life that i have benefited from second
chances and i am aware that other people
don't even get first chances my wife was
all excited she's like like how do you
think it happened he said tell your wife
to imagine the most beautiful story
possible
and that's the truth i think he's now
learned to keep
some of these details private it is a
lesson learned after putting their
relationship on full display back in the
day
maybe you guys could get a little more
press for this though we're trying to
get some can you see if we can get in
the papers because i'm trying to get
could i call
a source tells et the couple is planning
on spending christmas together with all
their kids and ben is planning a special
gift for jennifer whether that's an
engagement ring remains to be seen in
the magazine out december 11th ben did
reveal one of the most important things
in life is being quote a good husband
hopefully ben also got candid about his
past struggles with alcoholism quote the
only real cure for alcoholism is
suffering you just hope that your
threshold for suffering is met somewhere
before it destroys your life a lot of
that pain is rooted in pain caused to
other people i think he's very proud of
the man he is today he's aware of the
mistakes he's made he's talked about the
pain he's caused people through his
actions and his decisions he feels good
about where he is in his life
[Music]